It was completely
unexpected and of course,
very disappointing to see
the attack on scientists
and on science.
And it's continued,
in fact, it's got stronger.
In this conversation,
you're going to hear about COVID,
the Wuhan lab leak theory,
attacks on scientists
and how we're gonna get out of this.
Unimaginable loss, eye contact only,
longing for touch, push back.
The extraordinary becoming the ordinary.
COVID has changed everything
and we still know so little about it.
Hello and welcome.
My guest this week
is the World Health
Organization's chief scientist,
Dr. Soumya Swaminathan.
Thank you for joining us.
Yes, thank you very much
for having me on your show.
The World Health Organization
was founded to guide global
public health policy in 1948.
You are the chief scientist,
what a time to be the chief scientist.
I wanted to start by asking
you about the politicization
of science and scientists.
How have you found that?
Have you been surprised
by it during the pandemic?
In fact,
that was one of the things
I was most surprised by.
It was completely
unexpected and of course,
very disappointing to see the attack
on scientists and on science.
And it's continued,
in fact, it's got stronger
over the course of the pandemic
and well, I think it has a potential
to do a lot of damage
and it's one of the areas
that I think we'll have to
think very seriously about,
going forward, not just
dealing with the pandemic,
but in general, when we are
trying to educate people
and for them to have more evidence
and data driven policies for countries.
I think that the element
of this kind of mistrust
and actual disinformation
will need to be addressed
and we need to work
with social scientists,
behavioral scientists and
as well as with communities
to really understand this whole phenomenon
and particularly young people,
I think we really need
to work with young people
to improve scientific
literacy, health literacy,
get them to think more rationally
to question information they see,
which just comes out the blue
and doesn't seem to be logical.
So, the WHO has actually
launched a big program
of work in this area that we
call infodemic management.
That's really looking
into the root causes,
encouraging more research.
It's a very multidisciplinary
area of work,
but certainly one of the challenges-
I was gonna say have you
personally faced attacks?
I have and I've faced attacks
for just ordinary things,
which I thought should
be non-controversial.
So, making statements that are based
on the available evidence
and facts of that time
and of course we have to change
and evolve as data has been coming in.
And that's again I think
been one of the things
of the pandemic is that
we've had to change
and adapt our guidance as we go along.
And perhaps that confuses people,
who don't understand how science works.
And they may think that you were wrong
to say that a few months ago
or that you don't know
what you're talking about.
So, I think explaining
also the process of science
and that it's a continuous
learning, continuous evolution,
continuous questioning
and as more data comes in,
we must change our views.
Yes, I mean in terms of the attacks on you
as information has changed,
how have they come to you?
Has it mainly been via social media?
Could you give me a flavor of that?
It's mainly been through social media
and I think, again this is
the first pandemic I think,
in the social media age.
And so I've seen both the
positives and the negatives.
The positives of course have been
that you can get your messaging across,
that you get a lot of
information from the social media
that you can be updated practically
in real time to what's
happening around the world.
The downside is that you also get a lot
of false information out there.
And then you get these
communities of people
who organize themselves to attack.
And that's what happened to me.
I was attacked on social
media by a group of people,
for whatever their vested interest was.
I don't know what it is,
but they genuinely believed
that I was misinforming,
whereas I was communicating
the WHO guidance,
based on all of the data that we look at.
Do you get very frustrated by that?
You were one of the world's top scientists
and you're being accused of lying.
I mean, when you go home
at night do you vent?
Do you get angry?
What's your reaction to that?
It must be frustrating to say the least.
It is very frustrating and as I said,
I was extremely surprised
and very disappointed.
Yes, I mean of course and
that is the the wider focus,
you say of course it's
because of social media.
I think what you mean by that
is that's the way they
can get in touch with you,
of course as well as
reading other information,
but who do you blame
for the politicization
of scientists and science?
I think it's a combination of factors.
I think it's the first time
that science has played out
on the front pages of newspapers.
So in general, people are not used to,
I mean, when was the last
time that vaccine development,
was discussed by laypeople?
There are hundreds of childhood vaccines
and other vaccines that have
been developed and used.
We've never gone step-by-step,
day-by-day into looking at these things.
So, I think one is the
understanding a process of science,
understanding about transmission.
All our understanding about
the virus has evolved.
And as that's evolved our
communication has changed,
our messaging has changed.
So, I think that's the first thing.
The second I think is the
issue that you brought up
is about the environment of trust.
And you can see differences
between countries
in how much populations
and communities trust their
leaders and their governments
and how well governments have
communicated their messages,
how transparent they've been,
how they've explained to people.
Let's talk a bit more,
about the World Health
Organization then and trust levels.
A key question,
I bet you get asked this all the time.
How did COVID start?
What is your understanding
as the chief scientist
of the World Health Organization?
So, from historical experience
we've seen that many
or most viral infections
that newly emerge have
been zoonotic infections.
So, they've come from an
animal host either directly
or through an intermediate
host to infect humans.
And starting from HIV,
from the Zika virus, from Ebola,
from of course SARS and MERS,
the other two major coronaviruses
that have infected humans.
We've seen that they emerge from an animal
and then sometimes through
an intermediate host.
So, in this case,
I think the genetic
sequences of this virus were,
are still pointing towards
an origin, perhaps from bats.
That's the closest homology
that we found in sequence,
bats have a lot of coronaviruses.
And so, there's about 96, 97% similarity.
But I think what we haven't
got is the exact how,
when and where did that jump
happen from animals to humans?
And that's important to understand
in order to prevent future pandemics.
Do you not think it's a bit
odd that we don't yet know?
It's not that odd
because even in the past,
it's taken many years
actually to understand
the origin of viruses.
It takes several years to know
that SARS came from civet cats
and MERS was spread from camels.
And similar early for HIV,
it took a long time to understand
that it came from chimpanzees in Africa
and the chimpanzee viruses then were able
to infect humans and changed.
If I may just intervene at that point,
of course it's important
to bring up the idea,
of the lab theory where
there's this concern
that it's been leaked from
a lab by accident or not
in China with scientists working in Wuhan.
Joe Biden has asked
United States Intelligence
to look into this.
US Intelligence now
believe the virus escaping
from a lab is at least credible.
Have you ruled that out to the WHO?
Nothing has been ruled out.
As you know we've had
this group of scientists,
an independent international
group of scientists
that have been working on this,
they've made two visits to China.
The last one was in February of last year,
there was a very detailed report
that was presented with several options.
And clearly lab leaks can happen,
have happened in the past.
And one cannot rule it out.
So, one what one needs
is to look at the weight of the evidence
and the scientists who went to China
and worked with local Chinese researchers,
felt that the most likely
scenario was the zoonotic,
the animal,
that it's come from an animal.
Now, whether it's a wild animal,
a domesticated wild animal
or a domestic animal,
but is it a bird or a bat?
That we still,
we don't know but the scientists,
the majority of them felt
that, that was the origin,
but they didn't rule anything out.
They had it on the list
of hypotheses and said,
"We need to examine all the data
"and do more studies
in the field in China."
You brought up the word trust
and World Health Organization,
last year in August the UK's
"Sunday Times Newspaper,"
published a damning investigation,
into what they call China's power grab
of the World Health Organization.
The key allegations amongst
that centered around the idea,
having been embarrassed
by the SARS outbreak
and the World Health Organization's
very public criticism
of China over that,
that officials from China,
ever since have done as much as they can
to have as much control at the WHO.
As the chief scientist of the WHO
what do you make of that allegation?
I can tell you
that there's no truth
behind those allegations.
The World Health Organization,
first of all is made up
of its 194 member states.
And we are governed,
in fact, we have now going
on in the building behind me,
the executive board,
where the of course the executive board,
consists of 34 of the
member states that rotate.
They are the ones who make policy.
They determine the way that WHO works.
They set our priorities,
they agree on our funding.
And we then follow the program
of work that's set out.
We also, another thing that's
important to understand
is WHO works through global
networks of scientists.
And so we have thousands
and thousands of scientists
and researchers and doctors
from around the world
who serve on our different committees.
And they provide the recommendations
that go into our guidelines.
So, it's not just a
group of people in Geneva
who can be influenced by any country.
So, we try to be as open and transparent.
So, you feel satisfied
that there hasn't been any undue influence
by the Chinese authorities over the WHO?
'Cause another reason I ask
is you mentioned that fact
finding mission to China.
And I think this is very
important about trusting the WHO
and continuing to have trust
in it as an institution.
Peter Ben Embarek,
a Danish scientist who led
that fact finding mission
for the WHO into the
origins of COVID in China,
said the team was put under
pressure by Chinese scientists
who made up half of
the investigating team.
He told journalists in August 2021,
that those Chinese scientists did not want
the lab leak theory mentioned
at all in the report.
Now I must mention,
he then retracted that statement,
saying it had been mistranslated,
but he refused to comment further.
The issue is that doesn't
help with this perception
that has built up with some
that the WHO is too close to China
and hasn't been able to trust
what it's been told in China.
So, we've said from the beginning
and this is why it's
important for countries now
that are going to negotiate
a pandemic treaty, right?
The special World Health Assembly
that was held on the 1st of December,
came up with this report
called "The World Together"
which is really looking at the future
and how do do we want it.
I mean, things could
have gone much better.
And what we need is for
countries to cooperate now.
Tomorrow there may be a
new outbreak emergency
in some other country, right?
We don't want the same thing
to be playing out over and over again.
So, the world needs to come together.
The member states of the
WHO the 194 member states,
need to come together to
agree on a set of rules.
It's not WHO that can make the rules.
They need to make the
rules to give powers to WHO
to do the kind of investigations
that will benefit everyone.
So, those are the kind of
discussions that will happen-
That sounds, sorry if I may,
that sounds like you don't
think you've been able
to do the investigations you can
and a slightly different question
is do you think China has been open enough
this time around with the WHO?
It's about powers that WHO has.
It's about the powers.
So, we work with countries
in a collaborative manner.
So, you need more power?
Yes, I think more power,
especially to investigate outbreaks
that could lead to pandemics certainly.
Do you think the WHO has been the leader
it could have been at this time?
There's also been some
criticism coming away
from the China side
for not declaring a
global health emergency,
until the 31st of January,
I believe in 2020.
Some people saying it's been too slow,
too cautious, not muscular enough.
In fact, almost too collaborative
to move to be a leader at this time.
Well, you can always,
in retrospect I think that things,
could have been done differently
or things could have been done better,
but the fact is that when
a public health emergency
of international concern was declared,
there were less than a hundred cases
of SARS-CoV-2 infection outside of China
and no deaths had occurred.
And again, I come back,
it's the Emergency Committee
that advises the director general,
whose recommendations the DG then follows.
So, when they first met
on the 23rd of January,
the majority felt that it was not time
to declare a public health emergency
of international concern
and that the DG convened
them again a week later.
And that at that point they said,
"Well, it looks like it is
spreading outside China."
And they then made the recommendation.
So, again it's a group of
scientists who looked at the data
that was available at that time
and made the recommendation to the DG.
After that recommendation was made,
the announcement on the 30th of January,
very few countries took it seriously.
Most countries just went
about, you know, the normal,
nobody was preparing
for what happened later,
a few weeks later in
Europe and then in the US,
because at that time, yes.
So, valuable time was
lost between the time
that the public health
emergency was declared
and cases started climbing in
many of the Western countries.
So, even though that was
a highest level of alert
that WHO can make.
Just as I'm asking you about
the start of the pandemic
and the declaration of it.
I think a lot of people wanna
hear about the end of it.
They wanna know when
will we know it's over
or certainly at a point where you can say,
"We're not in a global pandemic."
What is that point?
So, I don't think anybody can predict
when that point will come.
We are looking at scenarios.
And the scenario that
we hope will play out,
will be that in 2022,
we will have enough people
vaccinated around the world
to have that wall of immunity.
And we know now that the vaccines,
we have currently are very good
at preventing severe disease and death.
And so if we can build that immunity,
which I have to remind everyone
that 3 billion people around the world,
still haven't had their
first dose of vaccine.
I mean, that's shocking,
even though we've had,
almost 10 billion doses
administered worldwide,
it could either circulate at
a low level, infect people,
some people get ill,
but not a lot of people get severely ill.
It could also like influenza
have seasonal peaks
in the future or there's
a bad scenario as well
that we might get another
variant after Omicron.
That is not the mild variant,
but we could get a variant
that's as transmissible
or more than Omicron,
but also is more virulent or more deadly.
We can't rule that out.
And that's why we were saying,
let's not declare the pandemic over
as some people are doing now.
It would be foolish to
drop all our precautions
that we've been taking all of this time.
We need to continue that.
And hopefully by the end of 2022,
we'll be in a much better position,
because let's remember this is a pandemic.
So, one country cannot do something,
without thinking that
they won't be affected
by what goes on in
another part of the world.
A variant can arise anywhere and come back
and you're back to square one.
So, I think it's good if the
whole world moves together,
we still need to be cautious,
but it's too early to
declare the pandemic over.
You just mentioned of course,
the billions of people who
don't even have a first dose
in their body of the vaccine.
What do you put that down to?
Is it the situation with patents?
Is it the situation with countries,
richer countries hogging vaccines?
What is the block there?
Well, in one phrase if
you have to describe,
it's to vaccine inequity,
vaccine nationalism,
it's a combination of the things you said.
I think the beginning obviously vaccines
were in short supply.
There were limited
and it's incredible actually
that vaccines even got developed in a year
and that we've had
billions of doses produced.
If those hundreds of millions
of doses we had in 2021,
had been distributed equitably,
the way that the WHO had
laid out the framework,
let's protect all the vulnerable people,
around the world first,
it doesn't matter where they live,
so we can reduce deaths.
And then we can start
vaccinating the other age groups,
coming down to adults and
adolescents and so on.
Then maybe we would not be
seeing new variants now.
Maybe we would not be
still seeing 50,000 deaths
a week today.
Do you think the West,
the richer countries hogging vaccines
has led to the variants?
Yes, I think we can say that.
85% of people in Africa
have not their first dose.
This is a recipe for letting
new variants develop,
because a virus is transmitting unchecked.
And so I hope in 2022,
that we can focus on bridging that gap.
Have you had COVID?
Yes, I have.
How was that?
When was that in the pandemic
if you don't mind me asking?
It was quite recent and it was,
I was lucky that it was relatively mild
and I could isolate at home
and self monitor myself
and I felt better in about a week.
Okay, because of course,
so many more people now
have had the experience.
I just thought to ask you I suppose,
how it was for you having
been working so hard on this.
Yes, I must say that it was worrying,
because I knows so much about
the paths that COVID can take,
the complications that you can have
and also the possibility of long COVID.
So, I think having been
vaccinated really did protect me.
Of course, I was taking
all the other precautions,
but still some times the
virus still gets to you
and I had, yes, mild, mild
symptoms I should say.
And I kept working throughout actually,
even in isolation.
I was able to do that.
Okay, well, I mean that's good to hear.
We wouldn't wanna hear it any other way,
but I suppose it's just
when you work on something
and then you experience it,
it can change your view and
also your kind of understanding
and your empathy levels with it.
And of course the reason this
has become so real to so many
is because now more and more
people sadly know people
who've suffered very badly with it
or sometimes in the worst
case lost loved ones.
Has that happened in your life at all,
have you lost anyone to COVID?
Indeed.
I mean, I think during the Delta wave
that happened across the
world and in India last year,
I lost many dear friends,
classmates and family
members to COVID, yes.
So, it did impact me also personally.
I'm very sorry to hear that.
Thank you.
It's just, I suppose the reality,
we can talk all about the politics.
We can talk all about the
science, the lockdowns,
but at the end of the day,
it's just for other people
who I suppose haven't had
any exposure to the science,
like you say we never used
to talk about epidemiology.
We never used to talk about vaccines
and then it just became so real.
And how we get our heads around that,
psychologically it's been very,
very difficult for people.
And I imagine at the same
time as working on it,
you've experienced that.
Exactly, I think so many of my colleagues,
have been working around
the clock as well.
We have to remember the
healthcare workers of course,
who've have put themselves
and that's why I said my classmates,
doctors have died during
this pandemic, close friends.
And of course people at WHO
and all the other public health agencies
and the ministries of health.
So, it's had huge mental health impacts
on both on people who've been working
and seeing a lot of
suffering on the front line.
But of course also families,
young people in particular.
So, I think as we think about
coming out of this pandemic,
we have to focus not just on
the health impacts of COVID
and what we need to do to
build health system resilience,
but on the broader economy,
on inequalities in our society,
which have really come to the fore.
I mean, for me seeing some children
that have been out of school
for the last almost two years now,
I really worry about their future,
particularly poor children
who have not had access
to online education
and whether they'll be
into child trafficking
or early marriages and so on.
So, those are the kind of things I hope
that countries will think about,
thinking about the most vulnerable
and how to protect them
and how to build social
safety nets in the future.
Do you think we'll ever get over this?
Of course we can get through it
and hopefully get around it in some ways,
but those ramifications,
we're only just starting to think about,
the social, educational,
the impact on this
generation coming through.
We will come through it,
we will get out of it.
But I think it'll take longer than people,
are currently planning.
People think we'll be out of the pandemic
by the end of the year.
Yes, I mean the health
impacts of COVID hopefully,
we will get over it.
We're not going to get the virus.
We will learn how to live with it,
like with other respiratory viruses,
but it's the other impacts
on the economy, on society
and particularly on the vulnerable,
this is the time to really start planning.
And I particularly hope
that we can keep children at the center
of this rebuilding.
And the other thing is not
thinking about going back
to how we lived in 2019,
but to imagine a new future
where we will continue to be very cautious
and sort of looking at to see
whether there are new variants
or viruses emerging.
I think we have much better
surveillance systems globally
as a result of this pandemic.
And we can also put our masks on.
We know that even
if you've had an ordinary
respiratory infection or a flu,
it's good to keep your mask on,
because at least you're
not infecting your family
and coworkers.
So, I think we've learned a lot,
we should take into the future.
Thank you so much for talking to us.
I think that's a very powerful point
to bring our conversation to a close on
with regards to how we might not go back,
but there may be learnings
from this time to take forward
and thank you for sharing the benefit
of your research with us.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for being with us,
until we meet again,
stay safe and goodbye.